our next guest uh is locked in with the
nfl husband all the time he's the uh
reporter for the nfl network as well as
the host
of the huddle and flow podcast with my
old friend jim trotter let's welcome to
the show mr steve why steve how you
doing buddy
i'm doing good hey ryan if you bump jb
smoove from being
rich's reporter now that would be a goat
move
i think so steve fan of the show i love
it yeah yeah absolutely
absolutely how you guys doing we're
doing good man thanks for thanks for
spending some time with us today where
where are you at right now you wanna are
you on a tour of the of the camps right
now
i'm in atlanta i was in houston earlier
this week for uh
like that was interesting to say the
least
how's the sean look at safety
you know can i clarify that real quick
sure people making a big deal of this
and ryan you know this
you know when teams are doing like
special teamwork and you've got like
eighty percent of the team doing special
team drills
right the quarterbacks and other people
will go through a group and they'll do
like blitz recognition or coverage
recognition
or rpo kind of backside linebacker
recognition
and the three other quarterbacks who
aren't going through that will dress up
they'll put those little skull caps on
their on their helmets along with like
the long snappers and all that
and they'll go through those recognition
drills i've seen aaron rodgers do it
i've seen other quarterbacks do it so
people are saying deshaun watson's
playing safety
that's what that is it is as common as
something i've seen for the past
10 12 years covering the united states
no it definitely is but it's in this day
and age steve where you post anything
without any context people are going to
make what they want to make from and
it's just
just the world we live in and it is
there's chaos in houston
don't get us wrong there's chaos there's
a new coach they're
exodusing talent from every which
direction uh
their franchise quarterback doesn't want
to be there he's got 22
assault allegations hanging over the top
of him civilly there's a
there's a criminal investigation going
on the nfl has
yet to act on anything i mean it they
say they're actively looking to trade
him yet i don't know a team that would
be willing to do something like that so
as you walked out of there there had to
be like a a breath of fresh air when you
walked into atlanta and saw where they
were trying to go
moving forward yeah it's real weird i
mean it addressed the houston situation
i mean first off there are teams that
apparently are engaging them in trade
talks
wow they're just probably you know look
they're probably trying to protect
themselves like if we trade for him and
we're willing to give up this type of
compensation we've got to have some
conditions attached
in case he is eventually suspended or
something like that
and you know maybe the texas said this
isn't enough yet
but it's so weird because there is a
feeling talking to some folks
that if he's gonna practice let him play
right
they're putting themselves in an odd box
by letting him practice they should have
just said
why don't you stay away you know stay in
shape
but why don't you stay away until we
figure some things out but now by
letting him be seen
out there on the practice field and
letting him take reps
you know individually and throwing the
ball better than any other quarterbacks
i'm sure at some point the player is
going to be like okay what are we going
to do like why is this guy taking reps
for everybody else if he's not going to
be here
and if he is if he is taking these reps
then why aren't we playing him
so it's a weird dynamic that they've set
themselves up with yeah yes if the nfl
hasn't made
a decision and they've they're letting
it go if i'm the houston texans i'm
saying i don't i don't care what you
what you want you're you give us the
best chance to win and
you're not going to harm yourself by
playing poorly you know you're going to
go out and play the best of your ability
because that's what desean watson is and
that's only going to
prop up his trade value if if and when
all of this is dismissed or goes away or
is adjudicated and in suspension or
punishment is handed down so it's
it's incredibly interesting let's let's
move on now to where you are right now
in the atlanta falcons because i
i find this to be a very interesting
organization they chose to
move on from julio jones uh and try to
to help their cap number a little bit
and do some different things on defense
because that's where they're gonna have
to improve kyle pitts was the draft pick
taken early
they stuck with matt ryan what are you
seeing from this
uh organization so far early in camp
it's a it's a weird it's weird ryan
because you know arthur smith is a new
head coach who comes over from tennessee
and the terry
fontenot the new gm comes over from the
saints
and you know i you know and i spoke to
them both kind of about what you know
what is
what is the plan right and the plan is
to try to build a competitive roster
to win as many games as they can with
matt ryan because they still believe
he's playing at a high level
um but they want to have everything in
place so when they eventually do make
the transition
which you know is coming in a year or
two that new quarterback is insulated
you know they've got they've got a ways
to go i mean this roster still
you know their safeties are you know
eric harris and drought harmony these
guys you know probably year to year
so they've got a bunch of year-to-year
vets um
at a lot of positions to help out some
of the young players
their offensive line is completely in
flux
um they've got two positions you know on
you know left tackle and right guard
they're locked down the other three
positions are up for grabs
without julio jones you got calvin
ridley who's a stud
russell gage is a pretty nice player and
then you've got like
10 guys fighting for three or four other
wide receiver spots
same at running back and that's just the
offense you know
for most of what i just said so they've
got a lot of holes to fill
they've got to figure out ways again to
be competitive but to also get some of
these young players right kyle pitts
looks like the real deal
haven't seen him in pads in practice but
you know when you see without pads it's
like that's a special talent so you get
why he went four
but you know this is a team you just
don't know they could be
really bad they could be middle of the
pack or they could catch some momentum
at some point
and win some ball games because they do
have their quarterback
we're talking with steve weiss nfl
network reporter co-host of the huddle
and flow
podcast uh everybody witnessed
um the entire off-season of the green
bay
nonsense and what ultimately took place
we heard from aaron rodgers for the
first time
publicly um about everything for about
how long was it rocking about 38 minutes
was the 32 minutes 32 minutes was this
press conference where uh it was
incredibly well articulated i think it
needed to be
um and and relatively transparent for
everybody to see even
even the organization that he is going
to be playing for this year what did you
what was your take away from
from aaron rodgers comments and
how this will uh how this season will
will come to fruition for for not only
him but the green bay packers as well
well look i mean i think they're going
to take another shot they're going to be
good yeah i mean the other there are
their offense going to be good i'm
interested to see defensively if they're
going to be as good because you know
even though we saw what happened in the
playoff game against tampa bay
that was still a pretty good defense you
know i i think they were top 10 in most
major categories
and now they've got joe berry who was
the rams linebackers coach now
taking over the defense so um
we'll see but when you go back to go
back to the press conference you know i
think this is it you know this is the
last year
right for him to spill tea like that to
basically say look if
you're going to draft my successor and
you're going to do not do certain things
with my contract
but let's go ahead and accelerate this
process so it sounds like
he wants to give it a shot because all
you've heard all along
is that he loves his coaches he loves
his teammates had to do with management
and you know i think he really spelled
that out in that news conference so i
think they're gonna go out there he's
gonna give it
you know his best shot this year and
then he's gonna say
go ahead and trade me they're gonna
probably be working on a trade
you know to to get him to wherever and
then
you know it's it's the jordan love era
so i you know and then but the
interesting thing you know is you know
devonte
was talking about hey i'm not giving you
a hometown discount
you know so he may want to be out unless
they franchise him
other guys may be out so
you know they they really better start
having a plan for the transition not
just a quarterback but how they're going
to handle their free agents
and how they're going to get other
players in there to replace them because
like as aaron said
a lot of folks ain't flocking to green
bay just to come to green bay they were
put they were coming there to try to
play with him
they would have a shot to win a super
bowl we're talking with steve weiss nfl
network
reporter um i want to get
your response to the the breaking news
today uh that's tim tebow catching a
a touchdown in jacksonville from uh
first round pick trevor lawrence by the
way um
no uh we're excited about that over here
on the rich eisen show
carson wentz right the off-season
uh transaction from philadelphia hoopla
there
former mvp candidate um back with frank
reich looked the part
in practice the last few days and then
we get news from adam schefter today
around the foot injury another and
now this you know further injury early
in camp wouldn't necessarily
bring a lot of news but it's carson
wentz who has been
shall we say injury-prone throughout his
career um
your takeaway from this news uh and the
impact on this this indianapolis colts
team in that south division
well you know you know this is where at
this point at training camp you're like
okay maybe it's a two or three day thing
right you're waiting to see now all of a
sudden they come out and they say like
oh boy i mean this is a
a two or three month thing you know like
oh man
um you know we better get some help and
we know one place they're not gonna get
a quarterback is to sean watson because
houston will not trade him inside the
division but
you know they're they're counting look
he he is seen as
the final piece even though they're not
going to ask him to put up
the same types of numbers they know he's
got the potential as philip rivers
did last year he's got the potential to
open up their offense a little bit
and to do some things i mean all you're
hearing is this team is super
bowl ready if carson went stays healthy
and doesn't turn the ball over
they're going to be in it to win it well
so far he's not healthy right now
so they just have to hope that it's it's
again it's a minor thing it's a day two
days three days
and that is not chronic because i do
think if he's healthy
from what we saw a couple years ago if
he gets his head back on right
um he could be a fantastic player and
he's in the right type of environment
they got a great culture
in indianapolis so i'm pulling for him
um you know again but the but the
durability thing
is absolutely a legitimate concern it is
and it's
incredibly disappointing uh i expect
from for
carson as well as is that indianapolis
colts
organization uh because they were
looking for some big things hopefully
it's a quick
thing that can come back foot injuries
are are always difficult to
to diagnose and and comprehend on how
long that will be steve one more thing
on carson
is he the quarterback who's under the
most pressure this year
oh he's one of them
i mean you know two uh you gotta look at
tua
because you know if if he doesn't get it
done you know there's huge expectations
on that team
and you know last year the injuries and
everything else in covet he kind of got
a flyer for
for his hot and cold performances so i
would say him daniel jones
um i think it's i think it's matthew
stafford
i think i think that trade how big that
trade was how much that
uh um you know mcveigh
is is putting into that
you know that bucket um i think there's
a lot of recall
a lot of pressure there for for matthew
stafford because i've talked to a few
people that don't necessarily think
this changes the la the la rams
interesting
um and and i've had to take a hard look
at it
matthew stafford's gonna have to be
exceptional i'd i do believe
and look you know for as much as you
know jericho was a turnover machine
last year but historically matthew
stafford
he gives that thing up now he's a he's a
13 14 pick guy
a year or two yeah but you know he'll
push it down field he'll take chances
and that's that's what sean mcgrady
wants his offense to evolve into
losing cam acres is a blow but that's
that's a nice that's a
nice call i did not think of matthew
stafford that's a nice call well done
well thank you yeah i just i i was a big
fan of
jared goff and i like the way he came
back in and played hurt in those playoff
games and and they were
you know a a smug look from aaron
rodgers knowing he had a defense he had
uh and a touchdown there from from
making that a game in the in the
divisional playoff game so
um you know i don't know what it's going
to look like in detroit for for jared
but
there's a i do believe there's a lot of
pressure on matthew stafford and
sean mcvay and that team moving forward
we are speaking with
steve weiss steve thanks for taking time
with us today enjoy the atl
uh hopefully i'll see you soon are you
gonna be in canton i will be i look
forward to seeing you there my man
yeah i'll be there um i'll be there next
week so uh
it's jb smoove's job right you're taking
tv well if i'm not doing that
uh maybe i can buy you a coke or
something like that how about that
perfect sounds great all right brother
have a great
trip up there and travel well enjoy the
preseason and
the camps thanks again thanks steve you
too take care take care
steve weish from the nfl network co-host
of
the huddle and flow podcast with jim
trotter
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here